un niño medio ambientalista asesinado un
ex coordinador de la guardia indígena
asesinado un ataque contra un convoy de
las naciones unidas- son algunos de los
titulares del primer mes del año en
colombia hasta el 29 de enero el
instituto in the path registraba 13
masacres y 12 líderes sociales
asesinados su director habló para
france24 sobre el resurgir de los
actores ilegales yo creo que hay
intereses ya de fondo de control
territorial de estas organizaciones de
sus finanzas de sus apuestas en
fronteras que también explican la
situación la violencia se ha desatado en
arauca en la frontera con venezuela hay
un lugar de paso para economías ilícitas
de minerales y drogas el ejército de
liberación nacional está librando una
batalla contra las licencias de las farc
por el control territorial hasta el 25
de enero human right watch reportaba 44
homicidios y al menos 900 desplazados
graves también la situación en el
departamento del cauca concretamente en
el norte corredor para rutas del
narcotráfico debido a su salida al
pacífico los más castigados están siendo
los indígenas en medio de su defensa de
resguardos territorios que se interponen
a los intereses de grupos armados para
france24 también habló la investigadora
stephanie ácido yo creo que el país
abrió una discusión una ventana
y por un tiempo el país pudo sentir lo
que era vivir en paz es un escenario muy
frágil porque a medida que el gobierno
dejó de cumplir no faltó a los
compromisos de lo firmado en los
acuerdos de paz
con un deterioro de han reconfigurado
los actores de poder en las diferentes
regiones y eso lo vienen haciendo a
punta de valle colombia celebró en 2021
cinco años de la firma de paz entre
estado y guerrilla de las farc mientras
la corte constitucional acaba de
declarar que ha habido una violación
masiva de los acuerdos